hi my name is Nicolas Wagner I am the
math and shot
coach for the Barney charter school
initiative I just did a video on the BCS
I approach to math instruction and what
we look for in a classical math
instruction at math class and now we're
going to take a look at singaporean
techniques before we get into that I'm
going to talk a little bit about the
story of Singapore in the late 1980s the
country or the nation state of Singapore
held a summit and concluded that since
their city-state was did not have as
many natural resources one of the things
that they're going to focus on was the
development of the intellectual capacity
of their children the government of
Singapore decided that they wanted to
revamp their educational system so they
when they did that they were operating
under to two guiding principles one they
wanted to raise standards
and two they wanted to change the
language of instruction to English okay
this these two things I think are
particularly helpful for for our our
purposes or for what we're using
Singapore Math for by raising the
standards they weren't they were very
intentional they didn't just push
algebraic concepts lower they were
really trying to figure out what
students could handle at lower levels so
a lot of math curriculum in America
today might might argue that there's is
advanced and I think that that's
probably probably accurate but the
question is how intentional were they to
make sure that matches up with the
development of the students abilities so
raising standards was was was very
important and the second point is
especially important to the changing the
language of instruction to English means
that they had a whole bunch of English
language learners students they had
students who were less familiar with
learning in that language so they've
designed it in such a way that the
students who are Els may have an easier
time understanding the math instruction
so there were three three people three
key researchers that influenced
influenced Singaporean instruction in
mathematics and those three people were
Jerome Bruner Zoltan Dean's and Richard
skimp so Jerome Bruner
may have had the biggest impact because
he believes that there were there are
phases of intellectual development we
learn we learn in phases and in those
phases that Singapore highlights are
these three the ones that are
foundational to Singapore instruction
that is going through the concrete to
the pictorial to the abstract so some
schools have done this really well in
the past not as not as as many as I
think would benefit from it then this
get this step right here has been added
and I don't think many schools in the
passive have used the pictorial after
the concrete to get to the abstract so
kids in some classes may be familiar
with using the manipulatives but then
they jump too quickly to the abstract
then there's a Zoltan Dean's
Zoltan Dean's and he has the
mathematical variability principle
attributed to him
again that's the mathematical very
variability principle and what that what
that is saying is for you to really
understand something you have to see it
in multiple ways so again this concrete
pictorial abstract that would be true
you're seeing it in three different ways
another thing to think about is when
students are using manipulatives
especially in kindergarten when they're
trying to learn numbers attached to
physical items if you only ever give
them the counting bears are the
attributes they're going to see only one
type of thing that they're counting and
so they might just assume this isn't
going to be true always but they might
assume that the only things that those
numbers can be attributed to are those
counting base so it's it's nice to also
incorporate a variety of types of
manipulatives so they see ok numbers
don't just apply to this one thing they
had they see it in a variety of forms
and then the third person is Richard
skimp and Richard skimp really focuses
on the balance between the relational
understanding and procedural knowledge
so there's a balance between relational
understanding and procedural knowledge
okay and what that is what that is
meaning is relational understanding is
really the development of the idea of
why we do something why why do we in
long division start in the highest place
value when in the other operations we
start in the lowest place value for
example mixing that you have to have a
balance between that the conceptual so
why this is why we do something ok and
then the procedural which would be how
we do something so going through the
steps what processes do we actually walk
through in order to do it you can't just
do it though you also have to understand
it so this is the why we do something
and this is how we do it or this is
these are the steps that you would do so
what we try to do and what Singapore has
done is tried to marry the concept with
the procedure so students aren't just
going through a rote set of steps but
they're really understanding why those
steps work going back to the concrete
pictorial and abstract
which you'll often hear reference as see
PA do you ever see that in a Singapore
text CPA approach or the concrete -
Victoria - abstract this is where we're
gonna use manipulatives so we'll use
those little counting bears I like to
say that we have apples for example not
the best at drawing so we we have a
drawing that is on box that you can look
reference if you're going to do a
training on this but and then you can
have say a lemon it looks more like a
pomegranate so this would be 2 plus 1
right and then you would combine those
things maybe and say that's two apples
and one lemon make 3 fruit - then we
would go to say the pictorial where we
would say 2 apples and a lemon equals 3
- so this would be more of what we would
call a bar model and we'll get to that a
little bit later - then the abstract the
2 plus 1 equals 3 bar models don't
necessarily look like this but just to
give you kind of the reference of a
pictorial so you'd go from from the
concrete physical items 2 to 2 pictures
to them to the abstract again this is
not a bar model reference so don't think
that that's the way that you draw them
beyond that a few other hallmarks of
Singapore Singapore curriculum is that
problem solving lies at the core
problem-solving is important again I've
already touched on this on what I'm
looking for in a classical mat math
classroom anyways but I think it's worth
repeating number sense and mental
arithmetic okay and then we have the
three big the three big things that
Singapore focuses on and I'm gonna list
those out right here just to highlight
them especially number bonds that's
poorly written number bonds and then we
they emphasize place value and then
lastly bar modeling which is getting
into the visual approach actually all
number buns and bar models are pretty
pre visual approach okay so number of
bonds place value and bar modeling the
materials that Singapore uses are really
designed so that there aren't many
distractions a lot of times we see in in
curriculums today kids playing a
basketball playing basketball in in the
textbook and you're wondering what is
that basketball player have to do with
what we're covering right now so that
the whatever is in the text for the
primary mathematics or the dimensions
textbooks that we recommend those are
very intentionally very purposeful and
they should be there and so maybe when
you're going through the teacher's guide
reference reference will look for why
are those things in there and the other
thing that it
is that Singapore does is spirals from
year to year it's not gonna spiral in
quite the same way that you would say
maybe Saxon Math spirals where Saxon
Math pulls in lessons from earlier pulls
in material from earlier lessons and
incorporates that into the homework
Singapore doesn't do that as much
what they do is year over year they have
a flow so you'll see fractions and and
third-grade fractions and fourth grade
fractions in fifth grade again and it's
a continued development from year to
year so on that note I think it's it's
important worth noting that you should
as a teacher be incorporating old
homework problems into the homework that
you're assigning so that the students
are are getting exposed to the old stuff
and not forgetting those things going
back to the conceptual and the
procedural being married tied together
they're less likely to just forget what
they learned however I still think that
there is value in in actually doing some
of that spiraling like Saxon math does
for them and I've already hit on this
but it's it's supposed to be a more
advanced curriculum in in the last video
that I did there's another another piece
that I already to you but I think again
it's worth highlighting you do not want
to have students seeing problems always
in the same way and Singapore does a
really good job of approaching problems
from a variety of directions the example
that I gave is that we're used to seeing
3 plus 4 equals 5 plus 2 equals 9 plus
11 equals in and so on and so forth
instead we want you to do something like
three points blank equals 7 blank plus 2
equals 7 and continue that on so or 9
plus blank equals 20 you get the idea so
changing up
way that the problem is worded so that
the students will will be exposed to it
in a variety of ways a note on that the
many states in their state test for
mathematics are actually incorporating
problems that look more like this and
what this does is it it develops a
deeper understanding or at least it's
testing for a deeper understanding of
what is happening in this problem when
we get to talk about number bonds giving
problems in a variety of ways with
number of bonds like this giving
problems like this are more manageable
so the students aren't as freaked out by
giving being given problems in this way
Singapore Math has a a diagram or
there's a framework that they use and
you'll see that framework in the form of
a pentagon and it's it's really meant
for problem solving I'm not going to
recreate that here for you but when you
see this it's in the textbooks and then
the teachers guides actually it's in the
teachers guides but then they're their
framework for mathematics incorporates
things that I think highlights a few
qualities that I really want to focus on
one is there's this this element of
metacognition and it's it's the ability
for students to monitor their own
thinking and and I think that ties in
well with what I said in the last video
where it says when they say that they're
they're able to know if they're on the
right track or not they can tell through
number sense through the development of
never sense whether they're going
towards the answer or not going towards
the answer the the other piece that I
think so
so metacognition is here then on the on
the same framework their process is the
same on processes I would say
communication is the the piece that I'd
like to highlight communication what I
what I think of when I see that on this
is the ability to explain things and so
again using good questions you're going
to draw out explanations and they have
to be able to communicate those those
concepts those ideas to you a few other
few other things attitudes is gonna be
on this piece right here and the
attitudes really the thing that I think
is most important I've already
highlighted in the last video confidence
the confidence to approach problem but
also perseverance so part of our
curriculum is actually a large part of
our curriculum is the development of
virtue and I think courage and
perseverance are two virtues that are
really well developed in mathematics and
in particular in Singapore math which
relies heavily on problem-solving the
courage to try something or to face the
problem is its significant and then also
to push through a problem to be
incorrect and and continue to try to
solve the problem even though you've
made a mistake and then also to finish
all the way through to the end of the
problem to find the solution after a
long period of time so allowing students
to struggle is is a good thing that's
okay I ask that you referenced the
that that framework on your own time I'm
not gonna redraw that for you so I want
to talk about now why did we why did we
get why do we choose Singapore math I
think that's probably a big question
that's on many teachers minds and the
reason we chose Singapore Math is that
one it's been at internationally
recognized by the ten Tim's education
test and that is the the trends in
mathematics and science where they test
fourth in eighth graders to see how
they're performing internationally
they've been at the top for the like the
lab I think about the last 20 years and
and so they have a proven track record
and then the other reason that I that
we've chosen Singapore Math is we wanted
a curriculum that developed the the
conceptual really well even though it
doesn't do work on the procedural
fluency as much as some other programs
so in the past I think we we may have
used Saxon for some things Saxon math
which does the procedural really well
but instead we want to focus for our
teachers and for our students on a
curriculum that has that contact
conceptual that concept based approach
done really well because it's easier to
to support or rather supplement the
concept based curriculum with more
practice problems than it is to develop
the conceptual out of a procedural or
practice based curriculum so that's
really the reason we've chosen the
Singapore curriculum there are a few
issues that have happened in America and
in the adoption of Singapore curriculum
which I think have been largely
addressed by by both hills dales
instruction in the
a few years and and trainings that we do
for for you but also by dimensions math
dimensions math has been specifically
designed for teachers it has been
designed I mean for American teachers
where it lays out in very plain language
what in each lesson you're trying to
focus on in Singapore they spend about
one to two years in math training and in
math education training and and
obviously that's not happening in
Singapore training in America there's
there's not a program there I think
there are some programs that are being
developed for that but currently there
there isn't a program that we offer or
that is readily available to teachers to
get that training so dimensions math
separates each lesson into its own
distinct qualities and says these are
the things that you need to highlight in
that lesson so they've done a really
good job of building a curriculum that
is designed for for the American teacher
so really the to complete this this
diagram that I have drawn we started
with the classical pedagogy piece and
and I said we're going to be talking
about Singapore new techniques and then
I want to highlight two two pieces the
first is again the pictorial approach
that is very specific to Singapore and
then the the other piece is the the
number sense and problem-solving
emphasis
so that's that's really it for the
Singapore training please join me for
the attack on number bonds thank you
very much